[Music]
all right
so did you guys know about you probably
heard already
that oregon just became the first state
to decriminalize
drugs the hard ones heroin cocaine meth
wait wait
the hard ones i thought it was just
mushrooms i don't know about that one no
no mushrooms was uh forgot some other
state but then oregon was that
it decriminalizes it where you just get
a fine if you're caught with it right
yeah
um small amounts are a fine um there's
also
addiction services instead of like yeah
instead of going to jail or serving any
time you have to go to like addiction
services or treatments and stuff like
that it was another state though that
just legalized uh
we're not legalized mushrooms but like
you know decriminalizing and things like
that no
i mean we've seen another we've seen in
other places that once you tell somebody
no they can't do it it just becomes so
much
worse than what it is and when you can
control it and treat it like a disease
you have better outcomes as far as like
violence the prohibition era
like we try to be like you can't drink
anymore everyone's like the [ __ ]
yeah i wish we could figure out a way
where it's effective because um
i thought in theory this would be
amazing because you know people aren't
gonna go to jail for this stuff anymore
but then what i realized is now we have
a lot of
drugged out people on the streets and i
mean if they're on wheat or whatever
that's different
but if they're on like meth crack all
the dangerous stuff
they're gonna when they're [ __ ] up you
know
they act crazy well the fact that it's
illegal doesn't make them not do it
that's the thing
no no but then at least the cops can
catch them and put them away and let
them sober up in the station or whatever
whereas if they they can't do that right
it's only decriminalized if it's under a
gram so if you
are an addict and you have a lot then
you're still gonna it's still a crime
alcohol i think yeah there's a few
things with that like kind of like how
alcohol isn't illegal but if
the public intoxication is illegal
driving while drunk is
if you're on meth i mean they might not
like throw you in jail for 10 years but
they might
put you away for the night because
you're causing like a problem well
because we know that the prison system
mainly is privately ran and they have
certain quotas and we've seen that we're
the biggest
penal colony in the [ __ ] world yeah
non-violent crimes are you know they're
just throwing people in so i'm just
thinking about
the people that get robbed and all that
stuff when you need more drugs
and then so like if you're a meth head
and you run out of money what happens
it's like you don't go to jail until you
commit the crime
not all meth heads and crackheads are
violent i'm just saying that when it
does happen
it's harder to keep them off the streets
usually going to jail doesn't fix that
addiction no it doesn't but my whole
point is
there's one conversation to be had about
helping the drug users right but i'm
talking about
preventing crime when you're strung out
like when you're when you're feeding for
drugs how do we prevent that
because that's the or how you protect
that person that's innocent in the house
from having to get burglars just like
with i mean
using alcohol as a comparison just
because we and we don't do it very well
side note like we still don't do that
very well with regulating alcohol
because you know dui
is one of the biggest causes of death in
america so clearly we've
regulated one substance and we're not
even doing it the best
but i think that's the only thing we
have to compare it
to and i think that's like the gauging
point getting to the root of it
manufacturing and selling drugs still
illegal
still completely illegal so where are
you going to get the drugs well they're
going to go to the
person selling it to you that person's
getting locked up but you are going to a
rehab
yeah and that's the important part is
that they also incorporate more rehab
so you get caught with it and you're
like feeding for more rather than
just like releasing you back into the
wild they're like all right let's send
you to a place
where experts and professionals can help
you what's really upsetting is that a
lot of people that have dui's have
multiple duis
they have multiple and most of them
commit the second
the second act we're not even having to
kill like running them over or whatever
like
you know so so when we use that as an
example i think that we still have a lot
of things to
fix with that and that drugs and alcohol
are pretty much gonna have to
it's really about just yeah fixing it's
been tested in
um countries in europe like including
portugal and the netherlands and
switzerland they've all decriminalized
hard drugs without
any rampant negative effects so france
has done this too where they have
rooms where you can just check into and
like if you're a heroin
mechanic for example like you can just
do it there and it's like a safe place
for you to just do it
because a lot of people d i mean we know
i just want to be able to smoke weed in
public like that's fine
yeah i don't know about that like if i
want to go to the [ __ ] park and smoke
like and there's no people around me
like i don't want to go to jail for that
you can't drink in public yeah you could
brown bag but you can't but you can't
smoke
but you can't smoke cigarettes in every
in in a lot of yeah that's a new lawyer
i do support drinking in public though
me too [ __ ] so much more fun leave us
around vegas yeah still fun walk around
asia use
walk into a store grab a beer keep
walking around yeah it's it's because
people here can't
control the attitude is the problem
that's why we talked about like the dui
thing
it's because like american attitudes
towards these things that you can't have
until you're 21 and now it's like
this like magical thing that's like i'm
not allowed to have it
so when you usually have it you're
abusing it you look at like
french kids who are like drinking wine
at like 14. yeah you know it's not a
problem and then they're drinking wine
they're when they're 41.
and that's no problem is there a super
right way or a super wrong way i feel
like everywhere is still trying to
figure it out but you know what the
angle
is like how are they going to make money
off of this and so sad because we know
that
the dui we showed that the the drugs
someone's going to have to fund rehab
somebody's sitting in the back and going
well okay so instead of putting them
here we're going to put them here how
are we going to fund it yeah well i
don't know i do i disagree i think we
can win the war on drugs if you just
give us a couple more years
and and like a couple billion more
dollars
a little bit more yeah just a few more
years guys we
almost got this problem is that we're
like a couple private prisons short yeah
and that'll fix we need to build a
couple more
that's it we got this thing on the ropes
man
you know there's some there's some of
our friends that have
definitely had the cool family or the
cool uncle or the cool whatever and they
had alcohol before
and they've kind of just like always
chilled out and then you have the people
that were so
caged in and couldn't do nothing and
then got to 21
wild out and they've never looked back
it's like you think of those uh catholic
students or catholic school girls
who are like had they have to be so
repressed and when they finally get out
it's like
like uh like my girlfriend she used to
go to a catholic school
before going to public school she said
the craziest people
in the craziest party she's ever
attended she's talking about all the
catholics
no repressed kids i learned all my bad
stuff at christian school
really got into smoking weed all that
stuff so
yeah that that's what's so funny about
all this [ __ ] too is that we always talk
about you know
uh repression and like oh my god like
it's so bad to teach your kids about
like what's going on with
their bodies for sex and [ __ ] but the
more that you play keep away the more
you're making them interested
forbidden it's like i want to try you
might have to explain things to my kids
and the best sales people are your
friends and they'll be like i try to eat
and this is [ __ ] good you know it was
crazy i
my dad i wish he found a little bit more
of a balance because let me tell you i
went to college and was like oh
this is nice i almost went into the air
force and my mom told me
i was getting recruited going to the air
force and my mom was like yo your dad
has had control over your life
somebody else is going to have control
over your life do you want that and i
went
no so my mom was the one that actually
convinced me to like to go and explore
and to do more she's like
listen once once you're done you're done
so like
have fun why did you want a chair for us
i'm sorry what was that chair you want
to go in the chair for us
i have family in the chair for so i can
say that my brother was in the air force
my dad was and my grandpa
um tested high in one of those things
but at the same time they had volleyball
so
they were gonna offer scholarships air
force volleyball yeah have you seen top
gun you [ __ ] ignorant [ __ ]
i forgot the movie but my mom but my dad
was so
strict my mom always kept on trying to
be like the little bit of light like
hey like go and do something because i
know it's gonna be really hard for you
when you get out
let me tell you i thank my mom for that
because i wanted to do way worse but i
always had my
like hey if i'm doing something not
supposed to do i'm somewhere i'm not
supposed to be i can call my mom she
always gave me that little bit of like
i think we have the same parents yeah
like that just that little bit helps out
yeah it really does because i caught
myself in a lot of situations to where i
was my mom was there to help me and my
dad we had to talk when i was older and
he was like
[ __ ] i think that's one of the reasons
why i rebelled so much because i never
felt like i had
access to the human being inside yeah
like if [ __ ] hit the fan no matter what
i knew it was still going to be
son calling dad or son calling mom and
it was never going to be like
the slight bit of vulnerability i
remember when i was 15
and you're 15 let me talk to you as a
human being so i'm like then i might as
well go to the homies house or go to the
you know
oh that's sad [ __ ] you know at some
point it was almost like take my
take me in i'm not going home take me in
my mom said that she wanted to go
to the ocean and drown me and herself
because she couldn't deal with what was
going on and when she told me i was like
your little ass i [ __ ] leave you
there and you can't swim you dumb [ __ ]
i wish that you just played a musical
instrument like the one that goes
where'd it go where
and she's like that's exactly what i'm
talking about
but imagine every [ __ ] up situation
you've been in
and how you got there if you really
thought about like if you knew what you
knew now
it was fun though i did i
i had a really sh nobody even asked me
to prom
like i had such a strict dad and
everybody was terrified of him
that i didn't even think people liked me
i just had a lot of issues
yeah and then i got into college and
then
developed other issues and then i became
an adult and i understand the
relationship now but
i would definitely do things different
so imagine people that get into like
drugs and a lot of the other stuff could
you
i don't know something i really
appreciate about my mom is she never
told me not to do things like not to do
drugs she would be like
okay you could do this but just so you
know i did this one time and i had a
really bad experience this is what
happened to me
and like she really freaked me out
because she's like go ahead and do it
try it
but like just i mean this is something
that could happen and
you just have to be okay with that yeah
i'm like i never did any drugs
my parents were like you're gonna do
drugs and you're gonna like it but it's
gonna ruin you just let you know she my
parents were straight up they were like
you're gonna like it it's in your dna
you actually come from people
who like doing drugs no my parents were
like straight up they were like yo
listen
you're probably gonna like it but it's
gonna ruin your life you're never gonna
have anything that you actually want
so go ahead but i'm warning you now and
i'm not gonna sugarcoat this or play
you're probably gonna like it
that scared the [ __ ] out of me knowing
that i almost had like no control over
something they're like no you're gonna
like it and i was like oh [ __ ] that no
what's wild is that we live in a country
that
they fought this war on drugs right
illegal drugs right but then they made
sure that the legal drugs like oxy and
[ __ ]
were spread to the [ __ ] masses no
problem making all these
people die from that more than cocaine
all these pharmaceutical companies
stacking billions not giving a single
[ __ ]
especially when they found out what was
really going on and covering it all up
so we can all pretend like oh yeah we're
trying to do the best thing for our
population but really it's all about the
money
yeah follow the money you'll understand
what's actually going on talk to your
friends and your family be real yes
we're on the drugs cia
yeah yeah thinking about it now i think
the best drug salesman were my parents
actually yeah so i think my parents
my mom would be like don't do drugs
because only
really badass gangsters do drugs
the tough ones that get all like all the
[ __ ] hoes
like and they walk they they walk around
they just demand respect
these are the guys that do drugs i was
like
so good be so wrong my dad is terrifying
he was like
you're not gonna go he didn't want me to
move to la my dad was like
nope because you're not going to want to
come home and you're going to do things
that you're
going to regret later it sounds fun no
he was like
you're going to be oh my dad straight up
scared he kept you protected he scared
the [ __ ] out because he was real he goes
listen you're not going to want to come
home because you're so [ __ ]
independent
and you're going to put yourself in
really messed up situations you're going
to do things that you're going to regret
so that you can stay out there
you know what go ahead then i was like
oh my god
no i'm better than that so i didn't move
i would have done it i would have done
it too sounds too funny but the thing is
i'm happy i didn't at that time because
he's a thousand percent [ __ ] correct
because if i got into a [ __ ] up
situation where i had no money
or whatever and where my headset was at
at the time i could not go home because
i was rebelling
which means i can't go home but my
parents were like you can always come
back and i was like
cool so i felt comfortable enough like
calling my mom or you know being able to
go because they were human
i was like cool if i'm gonna fail go
home
don't go somewhere else and don't dive
into other [ __ ] we know you can do now
you call my [ __ ] friend joe
cause he'll be there he'll be there
joe's coming to pick me up i
am mutant drunk and he'll do drugs with
you
[Music]
you